ein russischer top manager der nicht
mehr strom für putin war ist jetzt tot
der mann rechts im bild angeblich aus
dem fenster gefallen es geht um ramadan
of course von lukoil dem russischen
ölkonzern er sei sei es wegen einer
depression aus dem fenster gesprungen
suizid er heißt es fakt ist lukoil hatte
sich ganz klar öffentlich gegen den
krieg in der ukraine ausgesprochen und
damit putin kritisiert fakt ist auch
magath ist nicht der erste kritische
topmanager der jetzt plötzlich tot ist
schon mal auf ihn hier ihn hat es auch
erwischt putin staat alexander suh putin
auch er war top manager bei lukoil hat
starb plötzlich wegen der angeblichen
behandlung wegen alkoholsucht und ja ein
anderer mann igor wolf der ex vize chef
der gazprombank der sagt ganz öffentlich
dass das alles suizide ganz bestimmt
nicht sind und nicht alles blöde unfälle
ja dieser wolle projekte er ist
mittlerweile in die ukraine geflogen und
versucht das ganze von dort aufzudecken
und sagte auch er kämpfe dort inzwischen
gegen die putin truppen also wieder ein
top manager der ganz zufällig plötzlich
tot es im putin start
[Musik]